watching a movie at home just can't
match the experience of seeing it on the
big screen plenty of films are just fine
to watch any home theater or portable
device of choice but every year brings a
new crowd of releases that really need
the big screen to be truly appreciated
here's a look at some of the biggest
2018 movies the demand to be seen in
theaters first man in first man Damien
Chazelle is following up 2016's
la-la-land
with a period piece about the Apollo 11
moon landing starring Ryan Gosling as
the legendary Neil Armstrong it looks to
be a riveting drama that will shine like
a star on the big screen Giselle shot
select scenes with the IMAX 70
millimeter film and that's the way he
intends the first man to be sane the
film revolves around the most famous
lunar mission of all time and the Apollo
11 launch and subsequent landing on the
moon is going to look absolutely
spectacular on a massive screen the
predator bradda director Shane Black is
responsible for some of the better
action movies in recent memory
considering this the predator is going
to be a must-see
in theaters few genres play is reliably
well in theaters as action and horror a
big screen brings out the true power of
explosive action and an audience
amplifies the experience of seeing a
horror movie the predator looks to have
everything we love about going to the
movies wrapped up in one neat package
kraid 2 2015 soul the rocky franchise
make an unlikely come back with Creed
which shifted the focus from Rocky
Balboa to the son of his old rival
Apollo Creed the film nabbed a ton of
critical acclaim all while telling an
emotional visually striking story
they're trading shots the journey of
Adonis continues in Crete too and you
don't want to miss it in theaters seeing
a rocky movie on the big screen with an
excited crowd is a special experience
that doesn't come around too often
Halloween few cinematic boogie men have
delivered big screen scares quite as
effectively over the years as Michael
Myers and now he's back in a brand new
Halloween movie directed by David Gordon
Green of pineapple express Fame and
co-written by his frequent collaborator
Danny McBride the film sees original
protagonist Laurie Strode come back to
take on the man who ruined her life it
looks to be a return to form for this
series and with the greatest slash of
villain of all time returning to cinemas
for the first time in nearly a decade
you don't want to miss the chance to see
Halloween on the big screen venom
spider-man's goth symbiote twin takes
his solo big screen debut in venom and
this is definitely one you need to see
in a theater director Ruben Fleischer
who's put together a twisted brutal and
witty take on the popular Marvel
antihero aside from the great cast led
by Tom Hardy the effects look killer and
with an IMAX release to accompany its
standard theatrical run you aren't gonna
want to miss venom and a theater near
you
so many drugs a little time bohemian
rhapsody' generations of queen fans will
never get to see freddie mercury perform
live but Bohemian Rhapsody may be the
next best thing the biopic surveys the
rise of Queen including multiple concept
recreations but the big draw here is the
famous shows at Wembley Stadium Bohemian
Rhapsody gives fans a chance to sit in
the theater and see a reenactment of
Queens biggest concerts of all time on a
massive screen
tragically that's about as close as
anyone can get to seeing mercury tear up
the stage today
Aquaman Jason Momoa stake on the king of
Atlantis is one of the strongest
elements in the DC EU so far and the
full-length film starring the aquatic
hero looks absolutely amazing add in a
killer cast that includes Patrick Wilson
Nicole Kidman and Amber Heard an aqua
man feels like it could be something
special all that said the visual
spectacle of Atlantis itself could end
up stealing the shot the first trailer
gives us a tantalizing glimpse of the
lush underwater Kingdom filled with
beautiful design and color it remains to
be seen whether Aquaman will be an
aquatic slam dunk but a Killa cost
Atlantis and more Momoa is enough to
make it a must-see at your local
Cineplex here you can talk to fish
[Music]